TOMORROW NIGHT AT 7:00.
TUCKER UP NEXT IN D.C.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IF YOU WATCH THE SHOW FROM TIME
TO TIME YOU KNOW THAT WE REALLY
HAVE TRIED TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND
ABOUT THE ROBERT MUELLER RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
THAT SOUNDS INSINCERE BUT IT'S
NOT, IT'S SINCERE.
IF AMERICAN CITIZENS COLLUDED
WITH A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER TO
HURT THE UNITED STATES WE WOULD
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
WE WOULD NEVER DEFEND DISLOYAL
BEHAVIOR LIKE THAT, NO MATTER
WHO THE PRESIDENT WAS.
SO FOR THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY HELD BACK.
EVEN AS OMINOUS SIGNS
ACCUMULATED, WE STRUGGLED
AGAINST CALLING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION A PARTISAN
WITCH HUNT DESIGNED TO TOPPLE
THE PRESIDENT.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO THINK THAT IT
WAS.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S GETTING
HARDER TO DENY THAT NOW.
AS FEDERAL JUDGE T.S. ELIOT PUT
IT LAST WEEK, MUELLER IS SEEKING
ONLY INFORMATION THAT WOULD
REFLECT ON MR. TRUMP OR LEAD
WITH POSSIBLE IMPEACHMENT.
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
THAT IS A HIT JOB ON A
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED LEADER.
THE LEFT KNOWS THIS AND OF
COURSE IT PLEASES THEM.
REMOVING HIM FROM OFFICE IS THE
ONLY PRINCIPAL THEY RECOGNIZE.
BUT INSTEAD OF ADMITTING THAT
THEY LECTURE THE REST OF US
ENGRAVE TONES ABOUT THE RULE OF
LAW LIKE THEY REALLY CARE WHAT
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS.
OF COURSE THEY DON'T.
AS THEY POINTED OUT IN A PRETTY
SMART PIECE OVER THE WEEKEND
MUELLER WILL HAVE THE POWER TO
TAKE TRUMP OUT.
NO INSTITUTION WOULD.
THE ONLY INSTITUTION WITH THE
POWER TO PROSECUTE THE PRESIDENT
IS THE CONGRESS.
THE PRESIDENCY IS A POLITICAL
OFFICE.
VOTERS GET TO DECIDE WHO FILLS
IT.
OTHERS GET TO CHECK THE POWER,
NOT ROGUE FBI AGENTS, NOT PETER
OR LISA PAGE.
COULD THE CONGRESS.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAS COMMITTED A
CRIME THE CONGRESS CAN PUT HIM
ON CRIME, THAT'S CALLED
IMPEACHMENT.
THEY COULD DO IT TOMORROW IF
THEY WANTED.
IT'S IN THE CONSTITUTION.
IMPEACHMENT, THIS IS THE BEST
PART, TAKES PLACE OPENLY IN
PUBLIC.
THE REST OF US CAN WATCH IT AND
EVALUATED EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
THERE ARE NO REDACTED DOCUMENTS
OR LEAKED TEXT MESSAGES FROM
CREEPY FBI AGENTS.
THE WHOLE THING IS TRANSPARENT
AND THAT'S HOW DEMOCRACIES ARE
SUPPOSED TO OPERATE, OPENLY.
UNDERSTANDS THIS IS THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE.
AMAZING, BUT IT'S TRUE.
THEY BADLY WANT TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP, AND THEY SAY SO.
THEIR LEADERS LIE ABOUT IT AND
THEY DO IT FOR THE SAME REASON
THEY LIE ABOUT EVERYTHING,
BECAUSE ALL THEY CARE ABOUT
REALLY IS POWER.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SCARE VOTERS
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTION SO